the two types of mrna vaccines in the
second row here
um it's under the relative risk column
that we're looking at have
the the all-cause mortality is higher
than among those who were unvaccinated
as i believe the comparison here it's
1.03 where one is the baseline rate
whereas for the adenovirus factored
vaccines of which there are also two
types
j and j and astrazeneca the relative
risk uh also you know which is sort of a
stand-in for all cause mortality is 0.37
which is to say
the adenovirus factor vaccines
reduce
all-cause mortality
quite substantially actually and the
mrna vaccines do not in fact um you know
the numbers are so close as to
effectively make it make it equal um
although in fact it's
slightly higher well there are certain
nuances we have to add in order to
understand what these numbers mean but
the basic pattern is the adenovector the
adenovirus vectored vaccines
substantially reduced all-cause
mortality as one would hope from any
good vaccine
and the mrna vaccines the lipid
nanoparticle vectored vaccines very
slightly and maybe not importantly
increased all-cause mortality
so
and i should point out uh
in dr ben's interview which i suggest
everybody look at on unheard we will
provide a link to it
she is very clear on the fact that both
types of vaccine appeared to reduce
covid significantly
so to the extent that the mrna and mrna
vaccines have actually increased the
amount of mortality
right what it says is that they are
doing some kind of harm that more than
compensates for the benefit that people
got from the reduction in the amount of
covet now
i am cautious about this whole realm
because the studies that were being
looked at were studies that were done by
the manufacturers
and so the question is how
scrupulous were the manufacturers and a
lot of the work suggests maybe not so
scrupulous so was there a covid benefit
probably but we don't really know
because there's lots of reason to wonder
what happened here but the point is the
all-cause mortality number
is much harder to game right people
either died or they didn't and they were
either in the placebo group or the
treatment group exactly the point is
those numbers are actually with
short of outright fraud those numbers
allow you to do this kind of analysis
and they suggest that there is a massive
difference between the adenovirus
vectored vaccines and the mrna
vaccines furthermore actually it hadn't
occurred to me until just now as you
were talking um
you know what a vaccine is supposed to
do and what these vaccines particularly
do has been changing like they have just
been changing our expectations about
what we should demand of vaccines from
from the moment that we first had access
or hearing about them and then had
access to them through now and
a number of us are you know throwing up
the alarm over this but for the most
part people are like oh well they never
said it would reduce death it's just
supposed to reduce um you know symptoms
and make it you know less bad for you
which of course is not true that is not
nothing they ever said however
this suggests it doesn't matter so as
much as we have been talking for
uh you know a very long time
about uh focusing only on mortality with
regard to covid is too narrow a scope uh
that long covered is is real and there's
a lot of things that might be passing
under long covert that aren't that and
might be vaccine effects and this that
and the other but you know there is real
stuff there and this of course being a
franken virus we don't know we cannot
predict with as much
specificity or reliability what it's
going to do in the future because it
didn't evolve in a cave in bats right
and you know it evolved through serial
passage
um research in a in a lab maybe with
ferrets
so you know that changes expectations
about what to predict next but
regardless regardless of what other
benefits it may or may not be providing
if the mortality is the same ish
then that is the bottom line
well okay
the mortality is
the same-ish as as if you were not uh
vaccinated against
covet with these vaccines at all right
so in principle i agree that almost
everything ought to show up in the
all-cause mortality data with the caveat
that we need longer time well that's
that's where i'm going next part of the
problem here right is
that one of the things that is most
troubling about the way and there are
many troubling things about the way the
manufacturers ran their tests but one of
the things that is most troubling
is that at the point that they had early
numbers that they claimed said that
these things were spectacularly
effective
at preventing covid and very very safe
what they did is they vaccinated their
control group
right now
were you
forget what these people actually were
up to
were you a corrupt
pharmaceutical manufacturer interested
in hiding harms done by your vaccines
vaccinating your control group is what
you would do in order to obscure that so
not saying that that's why this was done
but i am saying
that basically there is a
predictable loophole in the logic of
science as it is applied to clinical
trials and the loophole comes in the
form of
should you be in the lucky position of
discovering a treatment that is so
effective and so safe that everybody
should want it then you are morally
obligated to treat your controls because
denying it to them would be unfair right
now
given that we know that that's the way
the
moral rules of
clinical trials work shooting for that
outcome in other words this is a
perverse incentive if only we can get to
the place where these things look super
safe and super effective then we get to
vaccinate our controls then anything
that
isn't safe about it will disappear
right which then of course fits with
the bizarre fervor to vaccinate every
damn person
right which also eliminates the natural
control group that comes from the fact
that a lot of us are you know go slow
you're intervening in a complex system
hesitant here
so in any case the point is this study
the study done by dr ben and her
colleagues is compromised by their own
analysis by the fact that the data they
were working from has a very short time
horizon because of the way it was
collected and then stopped being
collected because the control group
disappears
compromised through no fault of their
own and there's nothing they can do
about it right and in fact data do not
exist what they've said is that actually
we should be testing these things in a
way that we can uh we can compare them
directly and in fact
we couldn't do that here and that's
unfortunate but
the other point that i want to make is
with that what that means is that
there are two problems with the
numbers that we have for all cause
mortality here
one of them is that we don't really know
all cause mortality because what you
should be doing is tracking the
treatment group and the control group
two years out
five years out 10 years
20 years
and then you know ideally what you'd
want to know is the ultimate longevity
of the people who did and did not get
this
treatment and then we could say
something about what its net effect was
using mortality as a proxy for
good and bad health effects but we can't
do that here because a it hasn't been
very long so even if they had not
vaccinated the control group and these
numbers were continuing to inform us it
still hasn't been very long but it's way
worse than that because they rushed
these things to market having vaccinated
the control group which robs us of the
ability to say anything about
effects even a couple of years out
so that that is a significant factor so
my point is
uh 1.03 is just barely over one right
it's probably meaningless in terms of it
having increased the risk of death
however
you know what that doesn't contain
it doesn't contain anything about uh
the
increase in the rate of cancer that some
people believe derives
from the mrna vaccines right so
um
the point is let's say that cancer is
one of the outgrowths that these things
are carcinogenic in some way well then
the point is all of that increase in uh
mortality will be absent from this study
and will show up later and so um so the
point is 1.03
uh isn't
terribly bad it is conspicuous in the
following way now here this is sorry
that this is so complicated but um but i
think it's important to think of it this
way
okay you've got a number in which the
amount of mortality with the mrna
vaccines was slightly elevated over the
amount of mortality in people who didn't
get them but were otherwise matched
right
so close effectively effectively the
same right
however
what that means to the extent that these
vaccines appear to provide a benefit
from covid
that means that they did harm of some
other kind like cardiovascular and
here's the point if you knew that if the
work had been done well right and you
knew okay
these vaccines create
a benefit in terms of covid and
mortality downstream from it and they
create a harm by inducing other
pathologies the absolutely obvious thing
to do
is to not administer them to everybody
right those who's at risk comes
primarily from covid might warrant the
thing and those who have very low risk
from covid would should be protected
from them you know at the very least
given the other vaccine right so
the in
the fact that we are not in a position
to say look
the thing has an effect on covet as
predicted as far as we know right maybe
not but it seems to have some benefit
for covid it has some cost that nobody
who isn't at risk from kovid should be
exposed to
and the all-cause mortality could be
driven way down by not vaccinating
people who get no benefit on the coveted
side and have only risk from the let's
say cardiovascular side right that's the
obvious thing to do
and the fact that you know we're playing
some stupid game where the idea is
vaccines good where are they good for
people let's give them to everyone right
i'm sorry that's just not the way right
now and let's
not even pretend to do science and and
definitely get rid of the control group
[Music]